in discussing political socialization
we've talked a lot about factors that go
into how people develop their opinions
on government and politics your family
your friends your demographic
characteristics like your race or gender
they all contribute to your views in
this video I want to talk about another
set of factors that influence a person's
political views and that's political
events and political events include not
just elections or debates or laws but
things like terrorist attacks or
international incidents or economic
recessions these are external events
that shape a person's beliefs either in
the short term or maybe even for the
rest of their lives so what are some
examples of how political events
influence ideology some events can
change a person's party identification
or how strongly they identify with a
party for example researchers have found
that people who lost family members in
the September 11th terrorist attacks
became more politically active and have
identified more strongly with the
Republican Party since then sometimes
events can influence a person's
attitudes toward government and the
political process as a whole and here
we're not talking about which party a
person favors but rather their ideas
about government itself like either the
government trustworthy does my vote
really count one example of this is the
lasting influence of the Vietnam War and
Watergate scandal on public trust in
government you can see in this graph by
the Pew Research Center that since polls
started asking Americans whether they
trust Washington to do what is right
always or most of the time trust peaked
in the early Johnson administration then
crashed in the mid 1960s and 1970s and
has never really recovered since so
events that happened more than 50 years
ago have left a mark on public trust and
government that hasn't gone away but not
all political events have such a lasting
effect on beliefs some events influence
opinions for just a short term like
international events that influence
Americans attitudes towards other
countries for example you can see in
this poll data done by Gallup that the
public's favorable opinion about Russia
has changed a great deal over the last
20 years with revelations about Russian
hacking coming in 2015
leading to a sharp decline in favorable
opinions
the last thing I want to note here is
that researchers have discovered that
political events that happen when
someone is in their formative age or the
age from about 18 to 24 when people are
just getting out on their own and
starting to form an independent identity
events that happen then are more likely
to have long lasting effects on a
person's political beliefs and behaviors
the Great Recession in 2008 had a strong
effect on people in the millennial
generation many of whom were just
getting out into the workforce when it
hit studies have shown that this had an
especially strong influence on their
ideas about government and money
compared to other generations so events
can have both short and long term
effects on people's political beliefs
not just about whether they lean more
liberal or conservative but also about
how they think about government itself
and those effects may be felt more
strongly depending on what stage a
person is in their life or how deeply an
event impacts them personally